ladies and gentlemen there might be a
little convention going on but it's
john's birthday today
and he was like greg look i know you're
saying don't come in but i want to come
in today
because whenever i go over to your place
it's like
walking into pandora
it is it's like i'm being jacked into an
avatar and i can finally walk again
does that work it totally works it ties
into the video yeah no you're good
you're good gosh you're good honestly i
forgot the name of the city
until you're starting you're starting to
screw it up so you're starting to screw
it up though you better pick it up sorry
john i watch why aren't you
letting me down on my birthday guys we
are gonna check out today the new
trailer for avatar front avatar
i can do this from avatar frontiers of
pandora
the new video game based on the hit
movie that's the top grossing movie that
everyone's a fan of including us oh and
remember to like and subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
navi scown
it's like horizon zero dawn when it's in
video game context
it's retroactively making me realize how
much avatar looks like a video game
oh you're gonna be an avatar for the
avatar yeah
god if this isn't like oculus okay
crazy it would be kind of like being in
the actual
yeah avatar
okay so can you switch between like
first person point of view
oh it's just cinematic okay
maybe that's the game play
when you're in pov
for a second i thought the hair tail was
gonna become a parachute
jake sully
wow all right
it looks pretty beautiful
coming way before any of the sequel
steps
well john this is what i wanted for my
birthday
it did what the movie kind of does for
me which is make me go
the world of pandora is really beautiful
and it has this sort of tribal
quality that is very uh enticing to me
however yeah it does you know look like
a fantasy game where you fight you know
dudes in military gear that could be
cool
there are a lot of other that's the
problem is like avatar as a movie
introduces you to this very expansive
you know like
mind-blowing new world in some sense but
i feel like
in video game land this is much more
well-charted territory yeah it's true
i mean it looks cool built using the
latest iteration of the snow dropped
engine and developed exclusively for the
new generation of consoles and pc
this is gonna be an open world game and
you play as
navi and embark on a journey across the
western frontier a never
before seen part of pandora really
because it seemed like you were just
doing the sully storyline here
[Laughter]
well you know you gotta have that story
happening on the west frontier where we
haven't been yet with a different guy
like it's called avatar frontiers of
pandora but is there no avatar involved
you know what i mean are you playing as
just
a real navi yeah you're not like
plugging in maybe the implication is
that you the gamer
are the avatar person but in the lore of
the game it seems like you're a navi
i think what gets me more excited about
this and what they actually showed me
is the potential for it it's pandora and
you're playing as a navi and the
creatures you can
ride around and go fly yeah all the
crazy things you can do
and the battle sequences the fighting
and yes it with it being open world
lends itself to something that could be
very grand very rich but there's
something about the trailer something
that didn't quite hit it like it's not a
bachelorette it just didn't quite hit me
in the way i'm like
i kind of feel like i'm watching an
animated movie of a movie that already
felt animated
yeah yeah or something like there's i
don't know there's like a bit of a punch
or a bit of a grandiosity that didn't
quite come through this so it did feel
like i was watching like here's a demo
of what
avatar the game is gonna look like and
it doesn't seem as though it's geared to
be as sizzly as a lot of trailers
are yeah i'm kind of in the same boat
where i'm like this sounds like a really
cool game potentially and it seems like
something where it would be really fun
to just plug in and go explore i'm
curious to see what will make this
enticing as an actual game with a story
i wonder if james cameron was really
involved with this that's that would
make me excited if james cameron
because this is the world he created
like this is his world and it seems to
be what he's passionate about currently
apparently yeah well cause like his word
has gotten a little bit more
uh take it with a grain of salt over the
years with like you know
his terminator man this is the one i
feel like he's done that a couple times
he's got like eight of these movies
lined up it's clearly a big passion of
his and it took him a long time to get
the first one off the ground
and it's a world that's going to be
explored through the theme park and then
you got the movie coming out and
the the one of the many sequels coming
out yeah i think like the only way
to do this properly is to have jim
cameron involved that's the only way you
can do this probably yeah because jc
he's the only one who he's the
mastermind of the world it's like if you
have access to george lucas to do a star
wars game you do that if you have access
to
james cameron for avatar pandora you do
that but the problem
is to me i'm like this looks like it
looks like an adaptation of the movie
yeah yeah yeah yeah it doesn't look as
new or mind-blowing
even as a game and even as an extension
of the movie and then you start to think
well james cameron this dude loves new
technology and new ways of storytelling
and it doesn't seem to exemplify that
necessarily and so it makes me wonder
how much involvement he would have had
that's what i mean you know i wanted to
get a better sense of what it feels like
to be playing as but it's a first look
trailer and i guess i'm expecting a lot
more
just right now it feels like you know
back then when they were
how they used to do a lot of just
adaptations of
movies into video games that's kind of
what it looks like to me but a really
good looking version of that yeah yeah
there's one
on next-gen rendering technology yeah
anyway guys what do you think about the
trailer did you personally like to leave
your thoughts down below subscribe
but no john you close this out guys
subscribe give it a shot that
notification bell and hey
we'll catch you next time well you did
it john we did it you kept it short
so we kept this out for a short this is
the shortest out i am so
proud of how short this outro was you
kept it really really
fun i think we can make it shorter i
think we i think we can
especially if we do a retake all right
go for it or edit it out
entirely okay retake it that's right no
no that's better guys
you